afternoon everyone uh Chief Center I'm
here with mayor and mayor thank you for
the support
um
we're here to announce an arrest but
before before I do that
um I always start with that human
element
I spoke to uh takeoff's mother early
this morning and
um my prayers and I ask that all our
prayers continue to go out to her
and his entire family his close friends
city of Atlanta
and all of takeoff's fans around the
world yesterday evening
we arrested Patrick Xavier Brown 33
years old
he was charged with the murder of
takeoff
Brown was arrested again yesterday
evening
in the 14 700 block of
Sterling Green Boulevard it's located on
the east side of Texas
I'm sorry of Houston
again Joshua Cameron Joshua 22 years old
was arrested
on November the 22nd for felons in
possession of a weapon let me step up
and make a quick correction on the name
I had to misprint on my notes it's a
Patrick Xavier Clark 33 years old on the
rest of the suspect okay
the investigation's still ongoing we
still have a lot of people that we're
trying to locate and talk to so we will
be a little bit short on details here we
probably will not be able to answer all
of your questions but I can tell you uh
to confirm some of the speculations out
there the event was a private party
there was a lucrative dice game that
went on at the event there was an
argument that happened afterwards
outside the bowling alley which led to
the shooting I can tell you that takeoff
was not involved in playing in the dice
game he was not involved in the argument
that happened outside he was not armed
he was an Edison bystander was he
at the wrong place we already yeah it's
definitely wrong place at the wrong time
um
no evidence whatsoever to uh say
anything different